♪ [music] ♪
Give me one minute,
and I'll show you how Memorystore
can help you build blazing fast apps.
Memorystore is a fully managed
in-memory store
for Redis and Memcached.
It automates complex tasks
of provisioning, replication,
failover, and patching,
so you can spend more time coding.
Memorystore comes in various sizes
to fit your budget
and integrates seamlessly
with your apps within Google Cloud,
including the operation suite,
making it easy to monitor your instances.
For portability it comes
with an import-export feature,
so you can migrate your Redis instances
without any code changes.
Setting up a new Memorystore instance
is a snap!
You can create one using Cloud Console
by choosing the tier,
location, capacity, and version.
Or use gcloud command line
or APIs in Cloud libraries.
Once created, you can easily scale
your instances as needed
with very minimal impact
on application availability.
Standard high-availability instances
are replicated across zones,
so you don't have to do it manually.
Your data in Memorystore
is protected from the internet
using VPC networks and private IPs,
and also IAM integration.
For all the reasons we just saw,
Memorystore is a perfect choice
for not just caching
but also session management, gaming,
stream processing, and more.
So next time you're looking to create
a blazing fast app and save cost,
take a minute to look at Memorystore.
To learn more, check out
cloud.google.com/memorystore.
[whooshing]